Gee, nest egg!
My goodness.
Thank God.
It was only a dream,
it was only a dream.
A dream of the future.
Make sure to keep data denormalized.
What will happen to ShoppingList++
with denormalized data?
What will happen to [INAUDIBLE]?
[MUSIC]
Walter, do you have any idea when
they're going to turn the heat back on?
I'm just not sure how else
we're going to brave this harsh
San Francisco summer.
>> No heat if we can't pay the bills.
I guess we'll have to keep
burning these ShoppingList++
promotional posters for warmth.
Man, I really wish that we
could call JP right now.
>> Did someone say my name?
>> My gosh.
JP, where do you come from?
>> Well,
I've been living in your crawl space.
Like Walter, I invested everything
in ShoppingList++ during its heyday.
Although you had that pesky
technical issue about many-to-many
relationships and
didn't have any users yet,
I was sure it was going to be
a viable product, so here I am.
>> Hey,
since we've got nothing better to do,
why don't you tell us a little bit
more about that technical issue?
You can use the last of my worldly
possessions to help, my tablet.